you know nothing Jon Snow look at me and
tell me what you see this is a trick
everybody knew what this place was and
no one told me no one but you I'm not
going to get any better you know you
can't get any worse there's a lonely
room of the naked girl I didn't know
where to put it you know where to put it
and he asked for you himself it wants to
groom you for command you ever wonder
why the men of the Nights Watch take no
wives and father no children no I know
you do not know no one knows who's your
moonlight ride that tiring and what's it
terrified we beheaded everyone that ran
away for the night only ghosts would
guard the wall Who am I Who am I I
thought you said you couldn't know well
things said you can't you understand me
no you don't do you understand me I do
you're even dumber than you look there's
no shelter II there's no shelter
anywhere there is I could teach you how
to do it I know how to do it you know
nothing
you know nothing Jon Snow
you know nothing Jon Snow your grace
grace I didn't want to join us Jon Snow
I want to be free no I don't think so
how far are we but weaker think think
you don't know when we went to Castle
black we took the kingsroad no you won't
hurt me do know some things our vows
never specifically forbid intimate
relations with women what but what I
always have to say about other
activities is open to interpretation so
what's it like you wrapped up in they're
never wrapped up in you you written for
a little while you're more than just you
you wanna know I'm not bleeding poet no
you really know
there was so many before John only know
that because I've made that clone I
think they're in a bigger hurry than you
were look about
[Music]
there's no y know there's a proper
northern drink Jon Snow we're gonna burn
the bodies of your dead do you want to
say any words over them works what kind
of words funeral words I don't know how
the free folk do it but if you can't
understand why I want enlist my people
in a foreigners war there's no point
explaining I heard it was best to keep
your enemies close whoever said that
didn't have many enemies you know
nothing Jon Snow
it's one of the wildlings you brought
back says he knows your uncle Benjen
says he's still alive are you sure he's
talking about Benjen said he was first
Ranger said he knows where to find him
[Music]
listen this the old way you against me
did you really think that [ __ ] would
fight you man-to-man
No you have to be smarter than father
who needs to be smarter than Rob I loved
them I miss them but they made stupid
mistakes and they both lost their heads
for it and how should I be smarter by
listening to you that'd be so different
I'm a prisoner on this island you're
free to walk the castle the beach is to
go wherever you want except my ship I
wouldn't say we took your ship
I'm not playing word games with you it
seems unlikely that you became king in
the north by giving up that easily
everyone told me to learn from my
father's mistakes don't go south don't
answer a summons from the mad Kings
daughter a foreign invader Here I am and
northern thought what do you think I
should do
I would never buy a war I'm losing what
do you think I should do the Lord of
Light never spoke to me I don't know
anything about him I don't know what he
wants for me he wants you alive why I
don't know
I don't want ceci to murder me either I
could have stated my cell and saved a
great deal of trouble I did this I
should go so definitely murder you go on
I don't know how to ride a dragon nobody
does
until they ride a dragon what if he
doesn't want me till then I've enjoyed
your company Jon Snow